[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur LCP très
heureuse de vous retrouver dans Ça vous
regarde ce soir quelle protectionnisme
pour l'Europe alors qu'Emmanuel Macron
s'est montré très offensif à l'égard de
Joe Biden on va s'interroger ce soir sur
cette guerre commerciale et les moyens
des résister que nous-mêmes les
Américains c'est l'un des enjeux majeurs
de la visite d'État à Washington du
président français la conférence de
presse commune est en cours on en parle
dans un instant dans notre grand débat
le féminisme peut-il sauver notre
planète notre grand témoin ce soir et 3
dur comme faire c'est une icône de la
nouvelle génération féministe et le
publie future.es chez Alary édition la
journaliste Lauren bastide sera avec
nous pour la deuxième partie enfin nos
affranchis ce soir vu du perchoir elles
amont d'un Gabard revient sur le retour
du député RN Grégoire de Fournat après
ses 15 jours d'exclusion le regard de
l'avocat Bertrand Périer sur le travail
de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique à
l'origine de la démission de la ministre
Caroline caillot et puis tous les radars
le grand reporter Vincent Huger nous
parle ce soir du gouvernement vraiment
ultra droitier qui se prépare en Israël
sous la houlette de Benyamine Netanyahou
voilà pour le menu ce soir c'est
parti
[Musique]
l'Europe a-t-elle les moyens de se
défendre face à la politique de
subventions massive du made in America
c'est l'un des enjeux majeurs de la
visite d'Emmanuel Macron à Washington
entretient avec Joe Biden dans le bureau
ovale conférence de presse commune en
cours et puis dîner des tasses ce soir à
la Maison Blanche vous connaissez bien
ces dîners d'État François Clemenceau
bonsoir vous êtes ancien correspondant à
Washington aujourd'hui rédacteur en chef
du service étranger du journal de du
dimanche vous nous direz si ce genre de
Fast c'est le top du top en matière de
protocole peut permettre de faire bouger
les lignes bonsoir François girolles et
merci d'être là à nouveau sur ce plateau
économiste à l'OFCE ou commence la
concurrence déloyale y a-t-il encore des
règles en la matière vous nous direz
bonsoir Richard Berly et merci d'être là
correspondant France Europe du quotidien
suisse à les maniques Blic et
chroniqueur dans cette émission l'Europe
est-elle condamnée à l'impuissance face
aux protectionnisme
on sera tout à l'heure avec Christopher
Weissberg député Renaissance depuis
Washington qui fait partie de la
délégation
présidentielle il est représentent les
Français établis aux États-Unis mais
d'abord on va planter le décor comme
chaque soir avec vous Stéphane bonsoir
bonsoir Myriam bonsoir Monsieur si j'ai
bien compris sous les sourires et les
cadeaux de prestige rien ne va plus
entre la France et les États-Unis
[Musique]
alors j'exagère peut-être un petit peu
si j'ai bien compris ce soir Stéphane si
j'ai bien compris Myriam la France et
les Américains les Français les mains
sont redevenus les meilleurs amis ça
c'est quand même une bonne nouvelle
parce qu'il y a un peu plus d'un an
souvenez-vous
glacial son relation avec carrément
rappelé notre ambassadeur une première
dans l'histoire parce que les Américains
vous avez quand même marché dessus on
nous piquant un contrat de 50 milliards
à propos de sous-marins australiens vous
vous en souvenez j'imagine déroule le
tapis rouge est-ce que c'est pour se
faire pardonner justement à ça les
rencontres diplomatiques un petit peu
Thomas de sur les blessures d'orgueil ça
peut pas faire de mal enfin cet épisode
de sous-marin ça nous rappelle quand
même quelque chose c'est que les
Américains ne considèrent certes comme
leur plus vieux alliés Lafayette par-ci
Lafayette par là enfin au bout du compte
ce qui passera toujours en premier ce
sont leurs propres intérêt donc America
First c'est pas une expression inventée
par Donald Trump ça date de 1916 donc
c'est un peu dans le dans l'ADN
américain donc quand les intérêts de la
France et les États-Unis sont alignés
tout va bien on est content d'avoir
important liaris c'est 430 milliards il
y a aussi un plan de subventions pour
les chips c'est-à-dire les plus
électroniques de 50 milliards
de le répéter donc c'est pour ça que
voilà Thierry Breton qui commissaire
européen envisageait carrément des
mesures de rétorsion pour pouvoir se
défendre donc l'objectif de Macron ça
serait de convaincre Biden que plutôt
que de se diviser de se livrer une
guerre il faudrait mieux rester unis les
Occidentaux entre nous on écoute
les
certainement parfois les Américains donc
ce que voudrait éviter à tout prix le
président en écoute
et en quelque sorte que l'Europe est
donc la France devient une sorte de
variable d'ajustement
il part pas seulement de la France le
président aussi un peu au nom de
l'Europe quand il se déplace aux
États-Unis est-ce que les Européens sont
unis ou pas façon d'Américains
on sait bien que c'est pas toujours si
évident d'ailleurs récemment on a bien
vu que avec les Allemands ça marchait
pas très fort pour plein de raisons il y
a une un sommet franco-allemagne qui a
carrément été reporté tellement on avait
du mal à trouver un accord mais bon
maintenant que la pression américaine
peut-être qu'on va faire un effort
regardez Isabelle Barnetta Berlin
c'était la semaine dernière il y a 6
jours pour défendre l'idée voilà une
contre-attaque un boy européen acte une
mesure de protectionnisme européen donc
est-ce que ça va changer quelque chose
la rencontre je vous lis la dernière
dépêche qui est sortie synchroniser nos
efforts en matière d'économie verte et
Macron je dis ils sont d'accord pour des
mesures mutuellement profitables
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire des mesures
mutuellement profitables heureusement
qu'on a des experts parce que pas
forcément le même sens en français en
anglais merci beaucoup merci Stéphane
pour ce billet très complet et puis
comme chaque soir François colmanso je
commence avec vous je lui disais vous
connaissez bien c'est ces grandes
visites d'État entre Paris et Washington
déjà à quoi servent-elles et est-ce que
vous pourriez sur une échelle de 1 à 10
nous dire comment va la relation
franco-américaine sur une échelle de 1 à
10 je dirais plutôt 6 c'est-à-dire c'est
juste septième et c'est pas pour rien
que j'étais très mon article dimanche
dernier en prévision de ce voyage Roméo
et Juliette à Washington parce que d'une
part c'est une réflexion personnelle du
président de la République qui a comparé
la France à Romeo et les États-Unis à
Juliette sur le thème si Juliette vend
son gaz 5 fois plus cher à Roméo que à
ses propres amis et bien c'est que cet
amour entre les deux et n'est pas aussi
sincère qu'on le souhaiterait c'est vrai
que cette histoire de de d'économie et
de commerce elle elle introduit dans la
relation franco-américaine à une tension
qu'on ne soupçonne pas et que tout le
reste qui est positif la relation
militaire la relation du service de
renseignement la lutte contre le
terrorisme la grande unité de vue sur la
guerre en Ukraine y compris d'ailleurs
une forme de de convergence d'analyses
sur le fait que la Chine est aujourd'hui
un rival systémique des Occidentaux et
bien tous ces points d'accord finalement
sont au second plan par rapport à ce qui
préoccupe à juste titre la France mais
j'insiste les Européens parce que ça ne
trompe personne Macron et ta Washington
au nom des Européens ça c'est une
évidence oui parce que 27 aujourd'hui 27
mais il parle au nom de l'idée que ce
font les Européens de ce que doit être
la relation transatlantique pourquoi
d'abord un parce que c'est celui qui a
le plus de longévité au pouvoir au sein
aujourd'hui des dirigeants européens
deux parce que il y a eu le brexit et
qu'aujourd'hui la voie de de Ricci sunac
elle est pas inaudible mais elle est
juste à part et que Olaf Scholtz n'a pas
encore réussi aujourd'hui à devenir
leader en Europe qui permet d'imposer
une partie on s'est vu notamment aux
Etats-Unis d'ailleurs c'est pas un
hasard s'il était en Chine précisément
il y a quelques jours et donc Macron se
sent investi de cette mission qui
consiste à parler au nom des Européens
qui ressentent quasiment tous l'effet de
cette politique aujourd'hui
protectionniste aux États-Unis sur les
industries européennes et donc
légitimement il plaît en faveur des
Européens parce que la France n'a pas
n'exporte pas ses voitures aux
États-Unis ou en tout cas tellement peu
que ça n'a pas d'impact en revanche les
voitures allemandes c'est sûr que si
jamais les Américains peuvent pas
acheter de voitures électriques
allemandes là il y a une distorsion de
concurrence phénoménale et comme on
parle pas uniquement de dizaines de
milliards mais de centaines de milliers
on se dit même que il s'agit peut-être
de la politique à moyen long terme notre
politique industrielle la politique
américaine où on va construire les
voitures de demain pour justement cette
fameuse transition énergétique des trois
enjeux vous le gaz que la on s'achète au
prix fort que les Européens achètent 5
fois plus cher le protectionnisme avec
cette concurrence déloyale ou la
question du conflit en Ukraine c'est la
question économique le protectionnisme
le plus important alors c'est la
question économique parce qu'il y a il
faut pas l'oublier une équation
particulière à Emmanuel Macron qui est
le président de l'attractivité
économique il sait il s'est présenté
depuis le début comme celui qui allait
amener en France des investissements
étrangers et parmi ces investissements
étrangers notamment des investissements
américains rappelez-vous il était alors
ministre de l'Économie n'était pas
encore Président c'est lui qui a négocié
General Electric le rachat d'Alstom pour
les fameuses turbines nucléaires qui
depuis ont été rachetés par EDF donc il
y a chez Emmanuel Macron tout un
discours qui consiste à dire la France
peut accueillir des investisseurs nous
sommes un pays où vous pouvez ouvrir des
usines et là il y a un problème c'est
que ces usines et bien elles ne vont
peut-être pas s'ouvrir pour celles qui
étaient prévues alors François dit
Emmanuel Macron c'est dans quelque chose
auto investi représentant des Européens
là j'ai un petit peu de doute très
franchement je pense Emmanuel Macron
effectivement veut se présenter devant
Joe Biden comme la France
il est évident qu'elle entretient sa
relation personnelle avec les États-Unis
tout comme elle veut soigner sa relation
directe avec la Chine et un autre grand
pays européen dont on parle peu on en
parle beaucoup pour la garde Ukraine
c'est la Pologne la Pologne en juillet
le téléphone il est direct sur
Washington le dialogue il est direct
donc est-ce que ces pays-là seulement
c'est de là veulent être présenté par
Emmanuel Macron à Washington j'en doute
un petit peu bonsoir Christopher byzberg
on me dit que vous avez réussi à vous
connecter depuis à Washington où
êtes-vous précisément tiens puisque la
conférence de presse est en cours dans
dans le dans la Maison Blanche
non je suis au Capitole et en fait je
suis en train de déjeuner avec des
membres du Congrès qui étaient présents
hier avec le président à son à cette
rencontre avec les parlementaires donc
je suis je suis avec les sénateurs et
membres de la Chambre les premiers mots
du président américain président
français c'est ce sont des efforts pour
synchroniser je cite les les économies
dans leur transition écologique entre
l'Europe et les États-Unis ça reste
assez vague vous me le conseillerez la
France a-t-elle les moyens de faire
plier Biden sur la question du
protectionnisme
le président a été très clair hier je
pense qu'il a il s'est fait remarquer
avec avec son intervention de qui est
une intervention extrêmement sincère
sans langue de bois où il a dit très
très clairement les choses à
représentants américains et le
évidemment que il fallait plier Joe
Biden sur cette loi qui est déjà passée
et dans les effets second vont prendre
vont avancer dans les dans les jours qui
viennent et dans les saints qui viennent
il a plutôt dit qu'il fallait que
nous-mêmes européens on soit en mesure
d'avoir un agenda qui se synchronise par
rapport à ce qu'on fait les Américains
d'où ce terme de synchronisation qui
paraît peut-être compliqué mais qui est
exactement le terme approprié par
rapport à ce qui se passe actuellement
aux États-Unis il s'agit pas de faire
payer qui que ce soit mais plutôt de
s'adapter à la législation actuelle sur
l'Iran comment précisément parce que si
j'ai bien compris la France réclamait
quand même une des exemptions pour une
série de de ces produits industriels
concernant
ce grand plan de subvention massive
qu'on appelle les rats le plan Biden
is moi je suis je suis parlementaire je
ce que je peux vous dire c'est ce que
j'ai entendu hier c'était plutôt une
logique d'affirmer notre position de
façon très claire encore une fois sans
aucune langue de bois d'assurer que
nous-même européen nous aurons une
législation qui sera comparable à celle
qui a été faite aux États-Unis et
ensuite de travailler dans le cadre de
notre législation à
des accords avec les Américains
précis sur peut-être l'une de nos
industries le luxe par exemple
sur le luxe bon je pense qu'on est
extrêmement compétitif quoi qu'il arrive
en fait je veux dire le luxe français
aujourd'hui est apprécié et quand bien
même il y a des subventions américaines
pour leur industrie je suis pas sûr que
le luxe soit vraiment à risque c'est
évidemment probablement davantage sur
des sur des secteurs industriels même si
encore une fois peut-être sur les sur
les sur les batteries sur sur certains
secteurs spécifiques encore une fois si
tu négociations
industriel que d'autres secteurs de
services qui sont qui sont extrêmement
compétitifs aux États-Unis quel qu'il
soit donc s'il fallait résumer le bilan
de cette visite qu'est-ce qu'elles sont
nos chances de aller victoire il y en a
t-il véritablement
mais encore une fois
ça voudrait dire que il faut faire plier
quelqu'un l'idée c'est pas de se faire
plier l'idée c'est de faire comprendre à
nos américains nos amis américains que
notre position européenne doit être
aussi lucide que celle qu'on les
Américains sur leur secteurs le
président l'a dit très clairement hier
il a dit je comprends c'est America
First et moi je suis French first mais
pour autant il faut qu'on arrive à
synchroniser nos politiques et notamment
nos politiques commerciales donc moi
pour moi c'est pas l'idée de faire ici
c'est pas de faire plier les Américains
qui ont déjà voté leur loi plutôt de
préparer
merci beaucoup merci Christopher
Weissberg de nous avoir accordé cette
visio depuis Washington François
girolles n'empêche que il y a un peu le
choix et le froid là on entend bien que
synchroniser nos économies transition
bon voilà il y a pas grand chose à
attendre de Biden le plan a été voté
d'ailleurs de haute lutte c'est super
agressif ce plan là c'est les mots du
président il a raison de le dire ce que
nous demande en fait Joe Biden j'ai
l'impression c'est un peu de faire la
même chose c'est-à-dire il dit on fait
des subventions et ben vous avez qu'à
faire la même chose c'est à dire
investir dans la transition écologique
faire les mêmes aides pour les
industriels et puis on verra qui qui
remporte la bataille au final
industrielle sur la voiture on va en
parler simplement c'est pas les mêmes
règles du jeu en matière de concurrence
voilà exactement et je pense que c'est
la raison pour laquelle
Emmanuel Macron a raison de de poser la
question au niveau européen puisque à la
fois la la politique de la concurrence
et la politique du commerce se passe se
passe au niveau européen en fait et donc
la politique la politique commerciale
c'est Manuel Macron veut changer les
règles notamment mettre des règles de
protectionnisme au niveau des frontières
de l'Europe en fait c'est au niveau de
l'Europe que ça va se passer de la même
façon les aides d'État sont accordés
discutés avec la Commission européenne
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on veut faire quelque
chose de similaire que ce Joe Biden a
fait aux Etats-Unis en fait faut
demander l'autorisation à la Commission
européenne pour avoir la possibilité de
faire ça et généralement en tout cas
dans les dernières années en particulier
dans les 40 dernières années la
Commission européenne a plutôt été
réticente à ce genre de politique
industrielle à l'ancienne un peu
colbertiste presque françaises on aura
envie de dire de l'État diriger ce qui
décide de mettre l'argent sur certains
secteurs spécifiquement c'est quelque
chose qu'on a essayé à la limite la
construction européenne c'est vrai que
la concurrence libre et non faussée
c'était l'expression à l'aide
d'elle-même réguler par la vertu
concurrentielle les prix mondiaux et on
est un peu toujours dans ce schéma là
c'est à dire on a l'impression d'être un
peu trahi par les Américains sur ses
règles qu'ils ont largement contribué à
pousser à mettre en place y compris en
Europe on sait très bien que les accords
du gate au départ et puis l'OMC en fait
ce qu'il en reste ont été poussés au
départ par les États-Unis donc on a
l'impression d'être un peu trahi parce
que en quelque sorte on suit les règles
qui ont été largement édictées ou en
tout cas impulsés est-ce qu'on n'est pas
trop naïf on a l'impression
non mais c'est c'est toujours la même
sujet ces histoires de guerre
commerciale ou en tout cas de
concurrence des loyal entre les
Américains et les Européens et parmi eux
la France ça fait des décennies qu'on
est face à ce genre de difficultés ça a
été le cas sous le président bouche ou
le président Trump sous le président
Clinton sous le président Obama il y a
toujours eu des querelles commerciales
et pourtant on n'a jamais dénoncé les
États-Unis comme n’étant plus des alliés
loyaux on a essayé de résoudre ces ces
difficultés est-ce qu'on est parvenu et
la vraie question c'est quel est votre
levier quel est le rapport de force et
c'est pas pour rien que demain à
Washington se tient une réunion
précisément entre-européens et
américains sur l'énergie et la
technologie ça comprend une partie du
dossier qu'on évoque ce soir mais c'est
bien pour essayer de trouver des règles
communes des arrangements et de faire en
sorte que ce soit pas une guerre qui
soit perdante perdante parce que au bout
du compte c'est exactement ce que dit
Macron il dit le risque de division
c'est pas un risque de division on va se
faire la guerre au canon de le pouvoir
que des deux côtés de l'AT on mène deux
politiques tellement différentes et bien
qu'il y a un moment où on n'est plus en
phase et ne plus être en phase dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui qui est si turbulent
notamment face à la Russie mais
également face à la Chine et bien ça
fait les affaires de qui exactement et
bien des Chinois et des Russes et c'est
pas vraiment ce que recherche Hayden et
c'est pas du tout ce que recherche les
Européens la question c'est que c'est
plus difficile aujourd'hui de s'entendre
à 27 sur une politique commune vis-à-vis
des États-Unis et vis-à-vis du commerce
en général alors que les Américains bah
c'est les États-Unis comme disait
l'autre pourquoi est-ce que je parle au
Président c'est parce que c'est le type
le plus puissant de la planète il a la
planche à billets il a sa politique
monétaire il a sa politique commerciale
il a besoin d'en référer à personne
de l'inflation c'est sûr on voyait le
titre de L'Express cette semaine Biden
les Américains grands gagnants de la
guerre en Ukraine c'est un peu cynique
de le présenter comme ça mais c'est la
réalité avec la crise énergétique ils
sont gagnants mais ils sont gagnants
pour des raisons objectives qui ne
tiennent pas à la politique de Joe Biden
ils ont du gaz prendre l'Europe n'en a
pas ils sont ils ont des équipements
militaires à vendre en grande quantité
même si aujourd'hui leur stock d'armes
commencent à baiser l'Europe n'est pas à
même d'en fournir autant à l'Ukraine et
puis par ailleurs ils ont l'armée la
plus puissante du monde avec tous les
moyens d'observation et autres qui vont
avec qui nous fait payer si cher son gaz
pas moyen quand même donner quelque
chose sur le prix s'il y a une chose et
une constante dans l'histoire américaine
c'est que ce sont des gens qui croient
au marché et aux vertus du marché le
marché est en ce moment en faveur d'un
gaz très cher les Américains en
profitent entre eux
qatari ou que les Algériens je veux dire
on va pas non plus blâmer plus les
Américains sauf qu'on pourrait
considérer que comme c'est les Alliés
ils devraient nous faire une sorte de
rabais éventuellement mais je voulais
revenir à la sémantique qu'elle a son
importance le vocabulaire vous avez
remarqué ce que dit Elizabeth borne elle
parle d'un bail européen Act acheté
européen mais ce que fait baiden c'est
tout à fait autre chose c'est produire
américain et c'est pas seulement acheter
des produits américains or le problème
qu'on a en Europe il faut bien le dire
c'est un peu le problème le moment où
emman qu'on va revenir en imaginant
qu'on arrive à récupérer des usines de
production européenne on les met où on
les met dans quel pays on les met en
France on les met en Allemagne on les
met en Pologne alors donc là
Factory de batterie électrique dans le
nord de la France alors justement vous
m'amenez à la voiture électrique on a
compris que c'était l'un des véritables
enjeux de pouvoir dans cette guerre
commerciale entre l'Europe et les
États-Unis explication avec Maïté
vraiment
aujourd'hui en France si vous achetez
une voiture électrique qu'elle soit une
Américaine Tesla d'une marque chinoise
comme NiO une Zoé de chez Renault ou
encore la dernière de chez Volkswagen
une aide de 7000 euros vous sera versée
aux États-Unis ce n'est pas la même
histoire pour toucher 7500 dollars
d'aide les Américains doivent se tourner
vers une Ford une générale Motors ou
encore une Tesla en clair une voiture
électrique 100% américaine produite sur
leur sol une concurrence déloyale pour
les Européens la préférence européenne
de devenir une réalité je ne vois pas
pourquoi nos amis américains
réserveraient leur subventions à des
véhicules ou à des batteries électriques
produites exclusivement aux États-Unis
que les Chinois réservent leur
subventions à des voitures des batteries
électriques avec des composants 100%
chinois et que nous nous serions les
derniers avis de la crèche qui
continuent à croire à une mondialisation
totalement libéral et totalement ouverte
qui depuis la crise du covid est morte
la préférence européenne impensable il y
a encore quelques années et dorénavant
loin d'être un tabou et pour l'Europe il
est temps de réagir j'ai tiré la
sonnette d'alarme parce que je vois
effectivement l'impact et donc il crée
évidemment un véritable élément de
distorsion de concurrence dans sa qui
accepta force pour discuter ou bien il
faudra aller devant le MC et on va
envisager évidemment des mesures de
rétention avant de porter l'affaire
devant l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce l'Europe préfère donner du
temps au négociations voilà François
girolles on a bien compris au fond les
deux visions sur cet exemple très clair
de la voiture électrique est-ce qu'il
faut craindre une sorte de
délocalisation massive des entreprises
européennes vers les États-Unis pour
profiter de ce plan de subventions en
tout cas c'est un des objectifs je pense
qui est assigné à ce plan très
explicitement enfin
l'Europe mais notamment l'industrie
allemande est un concurrent très sérieux
des États-Unis depuis longtemps tout à
fait longtemps que les États-Unis se
plaignent du surplus commercial allemand
notamment et européen et ce qu'on voit
là c'est une forme certaines formes de
continuité entre la politique de jobiden
et celle de Donald Trump dont on pensait
qu'elle serait une parenthèse sur
l'histoire américaine ce qu'on voit
c'est que
il y a pas vraiment de différence c'est
ça devient un consensus presque
transpartisan alors
ça vient de la conférence de presse ce
soir est-ce que la création d'emplois ne
se fasse pas au détriment des Européens
qu'est-ce qu'il faut comprendre ça veut
dire que si les entreprises européennes
notamment l'industrie automobile
s'installe aux États-Unis elles auront
des aides oui mais ça veut quand même
dire qu'elles vont employer des gens
localement et des ouvriers américains et
c'est bien le but et ça et ça je pense
c'est quelque chose vraiment auquel
jobiden croit vraiment il veut
réindustrialiser la mairie il veut
remettre des emploie industriels bien
rémunérés ils pensent que la classe
moyenne a disparu que c'est en grande
partie pour ça que Trump a été élu aux
États-Unis et les ne veulent plus que ça
arrive faut souvenir que que Trump
vraiment a prospérer dans les états
anciennement industrialisés oui ce qu'on
dit le Pennsylvanie le Michigan en
particulier qui avait voté très
fortement pour Trump des états
historiquement démocrates et les
démocrates n'ont pas l'intention de
laisser ces États aux républicains
ça veut dire qu'on fait d'abord revenir
l'industrie récemment on va voir les
images Joe Biden s'est rendu dans le
Michigan pour aller visiter une usine de
semi-conducteurs c'est un enjeu colossal
à l'échelle du marché mondial leader
c'est Taïwan mais il faut des matières
premières de la Chine donc Biden a dit
très clairement maintenant on va
relocaliser la production de
semi-conducteur chez nous là il y a une
continuité absolue avec Biden
que
le TMC le principal
producteur de semis composants
électroniques dans le monde va pour la
première fois installer une usine aux
États-Unis à la demande des Américains
et parce que les Taïwanais ont compris
que c'était aussi leur intérêt s'il
voulait continuer à bénéficier d'une
protection des États-Unis notamment face
à la Chine évidemment et bien leur
intérêt c'est eux aussi d'amener leur
propre industries à aller vers les
États-Unis pourquoi pas vers l'Europe
c'est en discussion de sorte que
effectivement plus personne n'est
j'allais dire fragilisée parce que
on a pensé pendant très longtemps que
c'était tellement plus simple de
délocaliser aujourd'hui qu'on relocalise
on relocalise pas seulement nos
industries on essaye de faire en sorte
que nos partenaires puissent venir chez
nous si installer pour pouvoir non
seulement créer de l'emploi mais pour
nous faire bénéficier aussi de leurs
talents et notamment celui des taïwanais
qui est totalement indispensable on a
parlé aussi aux États-Unis durant cette
cette rencontre de l'industrie nucléaire
on a parlé même de l'industrie des
ordinateurs quantiques on parle de tout
cette c'est c'est nouveauté ces
innovations technologiques qui vont
faire le monde des 10 prochaines des 20
prochaines années il est capital
essentiel que évidemment européen et
Américains soient solidaires et se
partagent en quelque sorte les bienfaits
de ces innovations s'ils veulent pouvoir
continuer à garder la maîtrise de leur
destination sinon il y aura deux mondes
il y aura le monde de demain qui sera
là-bas de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
et il y aura le monde ancien le nôtre
ici face à beaucoup de périls qui
viennent de l'est et du Sud sont
impressionnants Richard berléon parle de
ces semis conducteurs de ce qui
nécessite voilà l'essentiel de nos
portables de nos voitures de nos
ordinateurs donc c'est des avions c'est
très important tout est en mutation sur
les 30 prochaines années est-ce qu'on
est dans la course en Europe l'état des
lieux c'est quoi la prise de conscience
des enjeux et de la nécessité de nos
défendre elle en est où en Europe je
crois que la prise de conscience elle
est réelle Thierry Breton quand il
intervient alors lui il intervient
vraiment au nom de la Commission
européenne donc il peut se prévaloir au
fond de la vie des 28 pays du monde
qu'il faut un moment donné rappeler aux
Américains qu'il y a des règles des
règles où ils ont participé qu'ils ne
peuvent pas unilatéralement les remettre
en cause mais on a deux difficultés la
première c'est que contrairement aux
Américains et toutes les crises récentes
ont prouvées l'Europe ne s'est toujours
pas réagir vite les Européens ne savent
toujours pas mettre en plan rapidement
là par exemple Emmanuel Macron revient
des États-Unis en lâche sol se revient
de Chine normalement on devrait avoir à
Bruxelles un sommet à 5 6 peut-être pas
l'ensemble des chefs d'État et
gouvernement mais qui disent voilà ce
qu'on va faire il y aura un sommet le 15
16 décembre à ma connaissance le by
européenacte il est pas au programme
donc voyez ça c'est la première
difficulté la deuxième difficulté
d'avance l'unité je crois qu'il y a une
unité je dirais sur le but l'objectif de
réindustrialiser aucun pays européen va
dire on ne veut pas d'usine le problème
c'est encore une fois où on les met qui
va qui va avoir ses emplois et surtout
quelles conséquences ça va avoir parce
que les pays qui auront les usines par
exemple de une famille conducteurs vont
acquérir une certaine avance dans ce
domaine il y a un mot qui est tabou qui
Emmanuel Macron a évidemment pas
prononcé c'est qu'en réalité une
politique industrielle européenne pour
qu'elle fonctionne il faisait quelque
part qu'elle soit fédérale voilà on sort
toujours aux intérêts particuliers des
27 on va écouter Emmanuel Macron qui est
revenu lors de cette conférence de
presse sur la relation franco-américaine
la France n'est pas venue ici demander
en quelque sorte pour son économie telle
ou telle exception sur les semis
conducteurs l'hydrogène les batteries
notre industrie on va continuer
d'avancer en européen on était là pour
se mettre d'accord sur une stratégie et
clarifier les choses qui méritaient de
l'être je considère que la discussion
l'a fait
François girolle vous avez l'impression
ce soir que la stratégie est clarifiée
si on souvient de Biden qui lançait
cette grande alliance de démocratie
c'était avant la guerre du crâne contre
la Chine à l'époque et contre la Russie
déjà il voulait embarquer l'Europe cet
enjeu là il est important est-ce qu'il
est il est suffisamment fort pour
embarquer aussi sur les questions
économiques alors c'est pas facile hein
faut se rappeler quand même que
Obama notamment à amorcer un pivot vers
la Chine vers l'Asie il a dit ce qui
compte maintenant c'est ce qui se passe
entre Los Angeles et New Delhi donc il y
a pas l'Europe dans dans ça les
États-Unis jusqu'à l'Ukraine je pense
nous voyons un petit peu comme voilà une
troisième un troisième acteur mais dont
il commençait à se à sortir en fait et
l'Ukraine les forces un petit peu à
revenir à se réintéresser à ce qui se
passe en Europe mais je pense que ça va
être très difficile pour l'Europe de se
mettre d'accord notamment sur un bail
européenne actes parce que les intérêts
sont très différents en Europe en fait
on dit que l'Europe est des
industrialisée mais surtout la France
qui est des industrialisés et Macron
évidemment donne la voix de la France
quand il les a mais son industrie depuis
des années encore à 20% du Pipe donc
très au-dessus même de ce que les
États-Unis ont aujourd'hui et de ce
qu'ils vont sûrement atteindre donc en
fait on a des intérêts divergents en
Europe l'Allemagne en fait est plutôt
surindustrialisée même puisqu'elle a un
excellent commercial et donc ce que ce
dont elle a peur c'est que si elle
commence à faire des rétorsions
commerciales contre nos partenaires
commerciaux ça se retourne contre elle
en fait et donc elle a pas intérêt à une
guerre commerciale et je pense que le
jeu par rapport à la Chine est aussi
très compliqué on voit que Olaf Scholl
s'est allé en Chine les entreprises
allemandes vendent beaucoup en Chine et
donc l'Allemagne a un petit peu aussi
entre deux elle se prend entre les
États-Unis s'ils deviennent
protectionniste qu'elle a du mal à
l'avant les mêmes intérêts
demain si il y a la guerre clairement
avec
à Taïwan par exemple c'est clair que
l'Allemagne à mon avis serait du côté
occidental c'est c'est évident mais les
entreprises allemandes se demandent
est-ce qu'on reste en Chine est-ce qu'on
continue à vendre est-ce qu'il y a pas
un risque François Clémenceau non mais
c'est vous avez un certain nombre de
responsables français qui ont eu cette
formule très raccourci et très
caricaturale qui consistait à dire que
le modèle allemand tel qu'on a connu
pendant 10 ans enfin au moins au moins
10 ans ces dernières années était mort
l'idée de pouvoir acheter du gaz à la
Russie pour produire allemand et vendre
en Chine ce modèle ne marche plus par
tout simplement parce qu'il affronte une
telle réalité en Russie et en Chine et
maintenant en Europe que ça des plus
possible donc comment les Allemands se
réinventent en plus avec une coalition
où les intérêts entre les écologistes
les libéraux et les socio-démocrates
sont si différentes donc l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles Olaf Scholtz ne
peut pas parler non plus au nom des
Européens aujourd'hui c'est parce que il
affronte ces difficultés là donc oui
Macron se sert de cette opportunité là
pour dire bah avançons essayons
d'avancer peut-être pas tous ensemble
mais au moins avec ceux qui peuvent et
ceux qui veulent et c'est évident que
bien sûr que la France elle a pas les
mêmes armes que les autres mais en même
temps elle a un discours et elle a une
forme de de soft power qui est quand
même depuis que Macron a été élu très
européen très engagé sur l'idée que
l'Europe doit se défendre qu'elle doit
être souveraine qu'elle doit être
autonome sur le plan stratégique les
Américains sont pas fondamentalement en
désaccord avec cette idée-là et surtout
pas Joe Biden pour qui précisément si
les Européens se prenaient enfin en
charge ça lui permettrait de
s'intéresser plus facilement à la Chine
et face à la situation
pour vous à ce qu'on est une industrie
forte alors peut-être pas forcément une
industrie forte mais une Europe forte
elle n'est pas forte que avec son
industrie elle peut être aussi forte sur
le point économique ou s'enfonge avec
des industries de service avec de
l'innovation avec des technologies et
oui avec une industrie mais donc ce qui
compte c'est le poids européen l'Europe
reste encore aujourd'hui la première
grande puissance commerciale au monde
donc ça c'est la toux que les Américains
connaissent et sur lesquels ils veulent
pouvoir influer d'une façon ou d'une
autre sortir de la naïveté c'était du
chef de l'État je vous propose d'écouter
un économiste de renom Daniel Cohen
parce que les économistes longtemps en
considéré comme ami il faut le dire que
le protectionnisme était un gros mot
alors il faut du temps pour au fond
accepter qu'on a changé d'air écoutez on
pensait que les problèmes du monde
allait se régler par un surcroît de
compétition je pense que de partout on
comprend que cette période néolibérale
de mondialisation est en train de se
refermer il a raison oui la raison sauf
que ça dépend d'où vous regardez et de
vous parler si vous êtes chinois
aujourd'hui vous continuez de voir une
mondialisation qui vous profite et
d'ailleurs la Chine en a besoin donc oui
c'est un regard occidental un revers
européen évidemment quant à Emmanuel
Macron il garde une vertu que je crois
que tous les Européens du reconnaissent
c'est qu'il met les sujets sur la table
de la même manière qu'il avait mis où
vous souvenez la question de la
mutualisation des dettes sur la table là
il met ce sujet sur la table de la
Maison Blanche c'est maintenant aux
Européens il faut bien le dire et pas
seulement la France d'être capable de se
prendre en main et de dire que fait-on
ensemble le problème c'est que le
ensemble tout le monde ne le conjugue
pas de la même manière François
Clémenceau les images elles comptent
aussi pour terminer ce débat il y a ce
dîner d'État on rêverait tous être
invités à la Maison Blanche ce soir avec
Donald Trump elles étaient violentes les
images on se souvient de la conférence
de presse il avait le président
américain et boosté de fausses
pellicules de la veste du président
français là on a tourné une page est-ce
que au moins avec Biden même s'il y a
une continuité on peut dire qu'on peut
se parler de manière amicale les
Français en tout cas les responsables
français aujourd'hui considèrent que Joe
Biden c'est quand même quelqu'un qui
dans sa carrière dans son expérience
dans ses discours et dans ses prises de
position est un pro européen c'est
quelqu'un qui connaît magnifiquement
l'Europe en tant que sénateur pendant
des décennies il a sillonné l'Europe il
était l'homme qui
venait au contact des Européens pour
mieux comprendre aussi à l'époque
c'était l'Union soviétique il a été un
spécialiste des questions désarmement il
connaît cette histoire là par coeur et
c'est quelqu'un évidemment qui a le le
passé de la Seconde Guerre mondiale
aussi donc il appartient à cette
génération qui comprend l'Europe la
difficulté c'est que ce qu'on appelle
entre guillemets l'état profond
américain ne voit pas forcément les
choses de la même façon parce que
précisément les tenants de l'Amérique à
first ils sont ils étaient républicains
hier avec Trump ils sont aujourd'hui en
grande partie démocrate vous avez
aujourd'hui justement dans toutes ces
dans tous ces états dans lesquels il y a
eu la bataille de 2016 et la bataille de
2020 regagner le vote populaire le vote
des classes moyennes le vote des
ouvriers c'est fondamental pour bidenci
perça il a tout perdu et 2024 c'est dans
deux ans donc ils ont intérêt aussi à
cette politique là et nous Européens on
a intérêt à faire en sorte qu'elle nous
pénalise le moins possible et bien merci
on va s'arrêter là merci pour cet
échanges merci pour ce débat on va
accueillir à présent notre grand témoin
bonsoir Loane Bastide et merci beaucoup
d'être là alors ce livre futur.es on l'a
compris raconte la manière dont le
féminisme
pourrait va vous êtes très optimiste
sauver le monde et la planète alors ce
féminine pour répondre à la question du
sujet que vous que vous défendez qui
qu'il faut construire il s'envisage
comment avec ou contre les hommes alors
avec évidemment puisque ce que je tente
de démontrer dans le futur c'est
justement que le féminisme la pensée
féministe ce que j'entends par féminisme
moi c'est vraiment des siècles de
recherche en sociologie en histoire en
économie a vraiment pour vocation de
métamorphoser la société tout entière et
évidemment en incluant les hommes donc
pas de guerre des Celtes inéluctable
quand le féminisme aura presque pris le
pouvoir non je suis convaincue que ça
peut se faire dans la douceur très bien
alors vous assumez une part de
radicalité quand même parce que vous
dites ou une forme d'exigence vis-à-vis
des hommes vous dites un acquiescement
mou et silencieux des hommes ne suffit
plus il faudrait qu'ils subissent
physiquement ce que on subit les femmes
pour vraiment comprendre alors ce que
j'envie violence alors ce que j'entends
par là c'est pas du tout le côté
revanche il qui subissent ce qu'on subit
par contre je trouve qu'aujourd'hui
quand un homme se dit féministe et
heureusement il y en a de plus en plus
il faudrait que ce soit un peu plus que
cette acquiescement là et que et que et
qu'il se confronte à la difficulté que
c'est encore de porter des idées
féministes dans la société aujourd'hui
en tant qu'autrice militante féministe
et je suis pas du tout la seule à vivre
ça on reçoit beaucoup de violence
notamment sur Internet nos idées sont
contrées de façon souvent avec beaucoup
de mauvaise foi et d'ailleurs ça a été
vrai aussi des féministes des années 70
un jour était le cas on les disait
folles à l'époque aujourd'hui les néo
féministes on les appelle comme ça parce
qu'il y a des différences des nuances
avec ce appellation derrière quoi parce
que je trouve qu'il y a une forme de
mépris dans cette qualification de Néo
féministe alors qu'il est absolument
indéniable que moi et mes concerts
aujourd'hui dans le mouvement on est
dans une continuité on est vraiment en
train de continuer de porter une parole
qui était celle de Simone de Beauvoir en
49 on dit vraiment donc les
universalistes d'un côté qui refusent
toute forme et les plus identitaires qui
demandent à être conscientisé pour vous
tout ça c'est pas c'est pas des
dichotomies efficace je pense qu'il y a
eu vraiment une un problème de
communication en fait parce que il y a
pas très longtemps j'ai eu la chance de
m'entretenir avec Michel Perrault caca
94%
des femmes et on était complètement
d'accord sur l'idée qu'évidemment que la
visée du féminisme de toute lutte pour
l'égalité c'est l'universalisme mais
comment atteindre cette égalité là sans
nommer les discriminations qui existent
alors une société purement féministe à
quoi ressemblerait-elle alors c'est
compliqué de le résumer en quelques
minutes sur un plateau j'ai exprès plus
libre de nous aimer on serait plus libre
de prendre soin des uns des autres il y
a la sollicitude il y a tout ça
effectivement
cette pensée du Caire donc le Caire C a
r e qui a un mot anglais qui veut dire à
la fois le soin mais aussi la
sollicitude l'attention à l'autre je
pense que c'est une idée déterminante
qui est portée par des penseuses des
sociologues des psychologues féministes
depuis plusieurs décennies et qui aurait
beaucoup d'applications en politique
d'ailleurs ce que je souligne dans le
futur c'est qu'à chaque fois que des
personnalités politiques ont essayé de
porter cette idée de guerre je pense
notamment à Martine Aubry il y a déjà 20
ans on lui arrive au nez à chaque fois
qu'on parle de la de l'importance du
soin voire même des émotions en
politique il y a un espèce de mépris qui
vient certainement du fait que les
institutions cette assemblées qu'on voit
derrière vous a été longtemps habité par
des hommes qui revendiquaient la
rationalité pure comme étant le seul le
seul outil valable en politique moi je
trouve que c'est compliqué quand on voit
le monde aujourd'hui de se confronter à
ce monde sans parler de peur sans parler
de tristesse et oui c'est des émotions
qui peuvent être aussi des moteurs
politiques très très forts et mobiliser
ces émotions féministes mais pas
forcément des émotions féminines nations
humaines des émotions humaines que tout
le monde peut leur sentir mais ce que je
veux quand même déterminer parce que
parler de ces émotions ça ne veut pas
dire qu'on se déclare d'autres
rationalité ou de toute logique moi
j'aimerais qu'on arrive à tresser à
tisser un espace politique où on puisse
à la fois avancer des chiffres mais
aussi des émotions et qu'en mêlant c'est
c'est de pendre la pensée humaine on
arrive à formuler des vrais solutions
pour l'humanité alors je voudrais qu'on
s'arrête sur un chapitre parce que il a
suscité pas mal de discussions en
préparant cette émission avec mon équipe
à la rédaction dlcp pour bien vous
suivre c'est un peu le plus déconcertant
il faut vous détricoter et vous dites
même avec amour avec des guillemets ce
que vous appelez la binarité du genre
alors si le féminin n'est pas
exclusivement réservé aux femmes et
d'ailleurs le masculin aux hommes ça on
peut le comprendre vous dites qu'il n'y
a pas de binarité biologique des sexes
alors pour vous il n'y a pas de sexe
différents il n'existe pas c'est de sexe
différents oui ou non alors j'ai bien
compris ou pas oui vous avez bien
compris alors c'est pas pour moi c'est
c'est notamment une biologie ce qui
s'appelle Anne Fausto sterling mais dont
la recherche a été corroborée par de
nombreux pairs qui a démontré que
finalement cette idée selon laquelle on
pourrait départager l'humanité en deux
groupes parfaitement séparés à
remerctment qui serait le groupe
masculin et le groupe féminin ne
fonctionne pas on parle vraiment de
biologie c'est à dire qu'on si on
regarde les hormones si on regarde les
gonades donc les organes sexuels si on
regarde des chromosomes à aucun moment
on trouve vraiment une une frontière
armée il y a une continuité en fait il y
a de la testostérone chez les femmes il
y a des hommes qui ont de l’œstrogène on
trouve tout un tas de de formes mais
possible et de taille possible les
utérus permettent de porter un enfant et
ça ça fait quand même une réductible
différente
on est d'accord mais il existe aussi et
ça je trouve que c'est intéressant et
d'ailleurs je suis heureuse que vous
m'en parliez parce que ce chapitre il
est rarement amené dans les médias il
existe aussi une partie de la population
qu'on appelle qui n'est intersexe et
c'est une partie pas négligeable de la
population mon selon les évaluations ça
va entre 1 et 7 des gens ce que je
trouve très intéressant c'est que
pendant des siècles on laissait ces
personnes vivre parce que ce sont des
corps sain ils naissent en or des
catégorisations sexuelles féminin ou
masculin et depuis à peu près on va dire
un petit siècle ces personnes sont
opérées c'est-à-dire qu'on va modifier
dès leur naissance par une opération
chirurgicale très lourde leur organe
sexuel afin de pouvoir les assigner à
une catégorie de genre donc ce que je
dis dans ce chapitre c'est que cette
acharnement à vouloir à tout prix faire
rentrer les êtres humains dans les
catégories de genre montre bien que
c'est une construction politique et
culturelle beaucoup plus qu'une réalité
biologique alors il ne reste peu de
temps il y a beaucoup de choses dans ce
livre d'ailleurs c'est très intéressant
mais ça nous apprend aussi à penser un
peu contre nous-mêmes c'est toujours
très très important je voudrais qu'on
dise un mot alors c'est intéressant
aussi toute le questionnement sur
l'hétérosexualité qui pour vous et
clairement une forme de domination
occidentale mais on passe moi je
voudrais m'arrêter sur l'éco féminisme
c'est très important dans le livre vous
savez qu'il y a une grande défenseuse de
l'écho mais si c'est Sandrine Rousseau à
l'Assemblée nationale pourtant c'est
vrai que elle portait alors c'était pas
elle mais l'une de ses soutiens une
motion au congrès de repécologie les
Verts qui n'a pas voilà qui n'a pas
réussi qui a fait plutôt un flop ce
courant-là n'arrive pas au fond vraiment
à exister d'un point de vue électoral
comment vous l'expliquez est-ce qu'il
faudrait un parti politique éco
féministe je crois pas j'ai plutôt
tendance à penser que les idées éco
féministes même féministes en général
doivent en fait infuser elles doivent
servir de boussole dans tout un tas de
champs en fait tout un chat un tas de
parties on doit pouvoir penser de façon
c'est toujours un peu difficile à
résumer mais disons que c'est cette idée
que finalement c'est la même force qui
est à l'origine de l'oppression des
femmes et de l'exploitation des
ressources naturelles jusqu'à
l'épuisement que c'est le historiquement
on peut situer un moment un basculement
dans l'histoire où se produit espèce de
binarité de gens se sexisme et
l'exploitation du vivant et qui se
double aussi avec la colonisation et
l'exploitation des peuples de
l'hémisphère sud donc il y a évidemment
des figures en Occident on sent rien de
Rousseau et l'héritière mais c'est aussi
il faut le rappeler un mouvement qui
n'est en Inde au Nigeria au Brésil et
qui a un rapport aussi avec la
mondialisation et vous piochez
d'ailleurs dans toutes ces références de
relier et de Vulgate absolument présente
et passée et surtout les continents et
c'est aussi la la force de de ce récit
qui est très simple finalement à lire
c'est très personnel et puis vous vous
adressez à vos lecteurs en disant allez
restez avec moi je vais vous expliquer
futur point es on a compris que
l'écriture inclusive que vous vous y
teniez c'est-à-dire c'est Alary édition
merci Lauren bastide je vous propose de
rester avec moi parce que avec plaisir
c'est l'heure d'accueillir nos
affranchis pour leur partie prix ce soir
elle a mon dagava pour vue du perchoir
qui revient sur le retour du député RN
Grégoire après ces 15 jours d'exclusion
le regard de l'avocat Bertrand Perrier
qui va nous parler de la Haute autorité
pour la transparence de la vie publique
c'est elle qui en quelque sorte est à
l'origine de la démission de la ministre
Caroline caillot et puis sous les radars
c'est ce gouvernement ultra droitier que
prépare Benyamine Netanyahou on en parle
peu mais heureusement Vincent le jeu va
nous en parler ce soir bonsoir à tous
les trois les affranchis bonsoir ravi de
vous retrouver on commence avec vous
Elsa vous revenez sur ce député Grégoire
de Fournat ça y est qui a retrouvé les
bandes d'hémicycle oui un retour plutôt
discret un Grégoire de fondage je le
rappelle c'est le député rassemblement
national qui alors qu'un député insoumis
Carlos Martins bilongo posait une
question dans l'hémicycle il a crié ça
les personnes secourus se trouve dans
une situation d'urgence absolue des
prévisions météo indiquent une
détérioration significative du climat
pas du tout ça a donné évidemment un
énorme incident de séance l'arrêt de la
séance des questions au gouvernement ce
qui est un Ferrari SIM la gauche la
majorité la droite avait dénoncé des
propos racistes lui c'était défendu en
disant qu'il parlait du bateau de
migrants Grégoire de fondnet s'il avait
été Copé de la plus forte des sanctions
ici à l'Assemblée nationale on appelle
ça la censure avec exclusion temporaire
il n'avait pas le droit d'entrer au
Palais Bourbon pendant 15 jours de
séance son badge avait été désactivés et
donc réactivé ce matin à 9h Brigitte
boucher notre journaliste était dans son
bureau elle interviewé pour savoir si le
comptait faire un retour fracassant ou
plutôt sous les radars écoutez je vais
être un parlementaire normal voilà qui
qui n'aura pas peur de s'exprimer sur
les sujets qui vont être débattus qui
continuera à faire son travail tel que
je l'ai fait depuis le début de cette
mandature et qui voilà n'aura rien à
comment dire à se reprocher mais non
plus sans forfait particulière parce que
voilà je vais continuer peut-être ce que
j'ai été jusqu'à maintenant
pour se députer aujourd'hui oui il était
là quand même de manière assez discrète
on l'a pas vu parader celle des quatre
colonnes par exemple là où sont tous les
journalistes mais il était bien dans
l'hémicycle pour l'examen d'une
proposition de loi des républicains sur
les retraites agricoles adopté à
l'unanimité on l'a vu Grégoire de
fournais mais on l'a pas entendu dans
l'hémicycle alors qu'il y avait une
rumeur comme quoi c'était lui qui devait
prendre la parole pour son groupe
finalement tout le monde a décidé de
faire de son retour un non événement et
ce que je peux vous dire Myriam c'est
que un homme surveillait ça tout près
cet homme c'est Renaud la baille un très
proche de Marine Le Pen c'était son
directeur de campagne regardé sur ces
images d'archives il est maintenant
secrétaire général du groupe ici à
l'Assemblée c'est pas un hasard s'il
était dans l'hémicycle il surveillait
sûrement peut-être des réactions des
réactions potentielles il y en a pas
vraiment eu il y avait pas de comité
d'accueil les insoumises et même pas
vraiment réalisé que Grégoire de
fournaise allait revenir il était un peu
interloqués sur les bancs de l'hémicycle
quand ils l'ont vu on a posé la question
à l'un que Adrien clouette on n'avait
pas calculé son jour de retour donc on
s'est dit est-ce que c'est bien lui qui
est là et évidemment bon ben ça nous ça
nous ajoute un petit point de vigilance
pour être certain que les débats se
passent bien est-ce que vous avez été
tenté de marquer le coup un peu de dire
allez on va quand même faire une petite
phrase un petit commentaire pas du tout
non on va pas
provoquer quelqu'un qui n'a pas besoin
de provocation pour déraper
députés RN et celui-ci en particulier
sont prévenus ils sont sous surveillance
sous surveillance des oppositions et de
leur présidente qui leur a demandé et
bien de peser chaque mot la reine
bastide j'imagine que ils vous ont
choqué ces propos du député
rassemblement national qui reviennent ça
la présence massive de l'extrême droite
à l'Assemblée nationale me choque chaque
jour je m'en remets pas bien 89 députés
c'est vrai que c'est cet historique
Bertrand vous vouliez revenir ce soir
sur la démission en début de semaine de
Caroline cailleux alors peut-être que
les Français ne la connaissaient pas
encore très bien elle s'occupait des
collectivités locales mais là hatvp la
Haute autorité pour la transparence de
la vie publique la épinglé pour avoir
sous-évalué son appartement parisien
c'est bien ça et alors vraiment pour le
coup
déclaration de patrimoine va de la
valeur de deux immeubles lui appartenant
lui appartenant elle avait minoré de
près de 4 millions d'euros c'est ça oui
absolument c'est aussi l'occasion de
revenir sur cette institution parfois un
peu méconnue mais décisive qui est la
pour la transparence de la vie publique
la hatv qui a été créé en 2013 dans la
suite de l'affaire Cahuzac dans l'idée
de moraliser la vie publique de gagner
en transparence pour la déontologie des
agents publics il y a pas seulement les
ministres ou les députés mais beaucoup
plus largement de total environ 17000
personnes ça va des merdes des grandes
villes au président des exécutifs locaux
et il doit à la hachettevp de
déclaration d'abord la déclaration de
leur potentiel conflit d'intérêt et la
déclaration de leur patrimoine mobilier
et immobiliers et là où ça devient
intéressant c'est que pour les ministres
et le président de la République et bien
ces déclarations sont publiées alors
évidemment beaucoup de transparence pour
le meilleur de la démocratie pourtant je
me souviens à la création il y a eu
beaucoup de critiques on a même parlé de
voyeurisme démocratique oui c'est vrai
je crois qu'on peut distinguer deux
choses on peut distinguer les conflits
d'intérêt d'une part et le patrimoine
d'autres choses d'autre part pardon pour
les conflits ça absolument normal que
l'on déclare ces intérêts parce que les
intérêts sont susceptibles d'affecter la
décision politique et on doit pouvoir
s'assurer que les décisions sont prises
en fonction de l'intérêt général et non
pas en fonction d'intérêt privé qui
serait masqué sur la question
patrimoniale ça me paraît plus douteux
parce que le fait de savoir quelle est
la superficie d'un appartement de
ministres quelle est la marque de la
montre ou de la voiture d'un député ça
me paraît pas en lien nécessaire et
mécanique avec la qualité de la décision
qu'il prend en temps que député ou de
ministre ont postule un lien entre la
situation de fortune et l'honnêteté de
la prise de décision je crois qu'au
contraire on peut être extrêmement riche
et parfaitement soucieux de l'intérêt
général et je trouve qu'il y a une sorte
de pétition de principe dans cette
exigence de transparence qui n'est pas
nécessairement exacte c'est vrai mais
Caroline cailleux elle connaissait les
règles vous pouvez le dire après tout
rien n'empêche d'être le pénis quand on
est riche mais là bien sûr
évaluée de plus de 4 millions au total
ce qui est considérable au demeurant
elle n'est pas la seule à s'être heurtée
à la hache a atvp on se souvient de
Thomas thévenou à vous souvenez la
phobie administrative Yamina Benguigui
Alain Griset et ce qui est assez
frappant c'est qu'on apprend dans la
décision de la hatvp que en réalité
Caroline caillou il y a un an avait été
averti de cette sous-évaluation et
qu'elle même ne conteste pas n'avoir pas
révisé sa déclaration de patrimoine
qu'elle savait donc soupçonné d'être
sous-évalué il y a là une sorte
d'inconséquence un peu surprenante de la
part d'une personnalité politique bah
elle va pouvoir maintenant avoir tout le
temps de refaire sa déclaration en toute
transparence de réfléchir à ce qui s'est
passé merci pour ce parti pris très
envers ce soir Bertrand merci alors
Vincent vous voulez nous parler d'un
sujet dont on parle assez peu le
gouvernement concocté
par Benyamine Netanyahou en Israël en ce
moment c'est bien le mot et éclipsé par
le calvaire de lucrède l'insurrection
iranienne et les convulsions chinoises
le signal Israël clignote à peine sur
nos écrans radars fâcheuses omission car
si jouent enceinte fin d'automne le
énième épisode d'une dérive inexorable
résumé dans ce pays à la destinée
singulière qui se prévaut volontiers de
son statut de seul démocratie du
Proche-Orient un premier ministre
convaincu de conclusion l'éternel
revenant Benyamin netanyawi échafaudent
le gouvernement le plus droitier de
l'histoire le fameux bibi qui reprend du
service il revient aux affaires à ceci
près que les affaires elles ne l'ont
jamais vraiment quitté Netanyahoo
l'insubmersible à jusqu'à la mi-décembre
pour bricoler un cabinet de coalition
dont le casting reflétera le verdict des
législatives du premier novembre il faut
donc récompenser les partenaires qui s'y
sulfureux soient-ils ont permis au
liquide d'arracher la majorité à la
cnesset et d'évincer le centriste hier
la PID à qui on se gardera de jeter la
pierre vous l'avez celle-là
citons le dénommait avimoise homophobe
compulsif promis un fauteuil de vis
ministre en charge de l'identité juive
et qui s'assigne pour mission
d'interdire la Gay Pride vice-ministre
ou ministre du vice et de la vertu
allait savoir autre ministre pressenti
le vétéran ariédery patron duchasse un
parti ultra orthodoxe séfarade lequel
des riz digne pour sa part le
portefeuille des finances sont CV plaid
pour lui il a été emprisonné pour
corruption puis l'an dernier reconnu
coupable de fraude fiscal et on parle
même d'un personnage jugé encore plus
inquiétant que le profil de ces deux-là
et oui plus inquiétant et qui sortira à
coup sûr du chapeau de Bibi fricoteur il
s'appelle Itamar bengwir et devrait
hériter du Marocain de la sécurité
nationale un bateleur jovial goyor ravi
de faire étalage de ses talents de
cuisiniers à la télé le X c'est que la
tambouille de ce suprémaciste juif
raciste un pénitent né en 2007 pour
incitation à la haine dégage un fumée
nauséabond dès sa prime jeunesse itama
rallie la mouvance du rabbin mais irkan
le quart relégué en Israël même au rang
de groupes terroristes et banni à ce
titre le jeune militant voit à l'époque
une admiration sans borde à barreau
Goldstein l'auteur en 94 du carnage du
Caveau des Patriarches d'ébrerons fatale
à 29 palestiniens en prière l'année
suivante il arrache au fait d'armes le
cabochon de la Cadillac dites sacrabine
ce traître coupable d'avoir scellé à
Oslo une paix au demeurant illusoire
nous avons eu sa voiture que les rôles
t-il alors et bien nous l'aurons lui
aussi exact quelques semaines plus tard
le général travailliste périt sous les
balles d'un allumé devenu avocat benvir
se porte volontaire pour assurer la
défense de deux ados accusés d'avoir
brûlé vif un couple d'arabe et leur bébé
est de nature à quoi a relancer un cycle
de violence certainement pas en tout cas
à l'oreiller puisque ça survient au
moment même où l'échiquier israélo au
palestinien plonge dans le cycle
infernal atentha meurtrier représailles
aveugles voilà quelques jours deux
soldats de salle ont été suspendus pour
avoir agressé à Hébron encore des
militants pacifistes benvir va faire le
ménager ici hurler l'un des deux
cogneurs vous avez perdu la fête est
finie pour les colombes comme pour les
territoires occupés il y a bien
longtemps que les lampions sont éteints
merci beaucoup Vincent voilà de nous
avoir éclairé sur ce sujet ça fait froid
dans le dos Lorraine bastide oui c'est
très inquiétant c'est très inquiétant je
voulais vous demander sur le droit des
femmes on les voit attaquer partout
entre l'Iran l'Afghanistan
la France progresse quand même sur ce
terrain là malheureusement je pense
qu'il faut relier en fait cette poussée
conservatrice qu'on observe partout aux
États-Unis en Israël en France en Italie
c'est la même chose c'est l'extrême
droite qui monte et l'extrême droite
c'est jamais un très bon signe pour les
droits des femmes allez avant de se
quitter journée mondiale contre le sida
vous connaissez ce
le vol du ruban rouge Elsa l'assemblée
s'est mise aussi aux couleurs de la
journée du Sidaction oui exactement mais
sur et bien regardez devant l'Assemblée
nationale place du Palais Bourbon on
pouvait voir effectivement ces rubans
rouges symboles de la lutte contre le
sida et puis alors ça a fait beaucoup
parler on trouve ça à l'Assemblée
aujourd'hui on a trouvé partout alors je
vais pas faire un quiz
exactement c'était une bonne idée pour
rappeler bien que le préservatif c'est
le moyen de se protéger contre le sida
petit cadeau pour tout le monde séance
de nuit ou le débat les affranchis vous
choisissez merci
Lauren bastide très belle soirée à vous
demain c'est Clément Méric aux manettes
je vous retrouve la semaine prochaine
[Musique]